the far left's unhinged reckless radical
socialist agenda was on full display yet
again today
extreme democratic socialists led by
jerry nadler
unveiled their corrupt scheme to pack
the u.s supreme court
and expand the number of justices from 9
to 13 in what is nothing more than a
brazen
power grab to destroy separation of
powers
have power in perpetuity and corrupt one
of the most sacred institutions
and get this for irony the democrats
core packing debacle is being undermined
by their own actions because remember
their quote we need nine campaign in
support then of merrick garland
back in 2016. don't forget before joe
biden was completely controlled by this
radical left socialist group
he thought court packing was a
boneheaded idea
he was right then he's wrong now take a
look
so we are here as a coalition
beginning this effort to ensure that we
restore justice to the supreme court
it was a bonehead idea the united states
supreme court
is broken it is out of balance
and it needs to be fixed it was a
bonehead idea
some people will say we're packing the
court we're not packing it we're
unpacking it
senator mcconnell and the republicans
packed the court over the last couple of
years
it was a bonehead idea it's time to go
back to
this tradition and have at least
13 justices it was a bonehead idea
when those seats are filled we will
finally have a court committed to
government
by the people it was a bonehead idea
it was a terrible terrible mistake to
make
and it put in question for an entire
decade the independence of
the most significant body including the
congress in my view the most significant
body
in this country the supreme court of the
united states of america
you see what i mean joe biden today is
nothing like that guy
now pelosi claims she's not going to
bring it to the floor but
you can't really believe her and then
added oh yeah she wants to hear from
biden's commission
which will likely recommend court
packing and next up for the docket for
democrats d.c
statehood puerto rico statehood
reparations
yeah ending the legislative filibuster
and abolishing even the electoral
college